if you totally believe in free tonight
just because you say you believe in
freedom but if you really want people to
think for themselves they're gonna start
thinking some things you don't like so
welcome I am here today with Dave Rubin
and we're gonna jump in with Dave Rubin
of the Rubin report one of I would say
my best political friends out there and
a real inspiration so a lot of folks are
trying to open their minds about
politics but first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over a policy genius so
over 80% of people think life insurance
costs double what it actually costs not
only that almost a hundred percent of
people think buying life insurance is a
pain in the neck because it is the truth
is a healthy 35 year olds can get half a
million bucks in coverage for less than
30 bucks a month and getting life
insurance does not have to be
complicated because there's policy
genius listen I know you think you're
never gonna die everything's gonna be
fine you know live healthily
well not true someday you will die and
your family will need the money that's
why you should get life insurance now
and policy genius is the easy way to
compare life insurance online in just
five minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers to find the best policy
for you policy genius has helped over 4
million people shop for insurance
they've placed over 20 billion dollars
in coverage and they don't just make
life insurance easy they also compared
disability insurance and renter's
insurance and health insurance if you
care about it they can cover it so if
you've been thinking about getting a
life insurance go to policy genius calm
it is the easy way to compare the top
insurers and find the best policy for
you you'll be saving time and money and
hassle and it's free policy genius
because comparing life insurance does
not actually need to be a pain in the
neck okay so I could not be more excited
to welcome my friend Dave Rubin here
Dave good to see you good to see you I
like that line if you die it's too late
it is that is how I live my life
basically that I better get it done now
because you never know well one of the
great things about Dave Rubin is that
the first time I was introduced you I
think was probably on your show oh we
knew each other before before I was on
your show and you are I think one of the
best interviewers in the business so
people normally see stuff like this and
expect us to see the chairs reversed
yeah but what's what's really fun about
this I actually want to ask about some
of the sent your own journey because you
don't actually get to talk about that
too much
very quickly though I just for the
record clearly by you being an interview
and you stole this for me I was the one
that came up with the idea of the
interview nice people sitting there
talking about you have culturally
appropriated it for me I just want to
put oh yeah and then just like
just like America we've been culturally
appropriate from others and then we're
gonna make the best of it make more
money so that mean that's our actual
plan listen if you make a better
interview show than me to me that truly
I'm not kidding that would be great
because that would make me do better I
love competition I'm not even saying
we're yeah but I love that that's the
point we this whole crew of people that
I'm sure we're gonna talk about we're
all rising together dancing where the
differences are and that's awesome so
it's like I would love the idea of oh
ship heroes doing a show and more of
these guys are connecting and more of
these ideas are not sauce it's awesome
and that's why I'm here yeah it's really
exciting so okay before we get to you
know what you referenced there the the
so called intellectual dark web but turn
joined by our common friend Eric
Weinstein yeah I first want to ask you
about your own personal journey for
being where you are because if you look
at your YouTube channel and you look at
the videos that have the highest hit
count there's still some from your Young
Turks days you know from the days when
you're in league with with our good
friend shank yeah girl and so so I I
want to ask you sort of for people who
don't know about your journey from being
pretty hard left yeah to being
open-minded about politics to the extent
that you know you and I are probably
much more in league together than
certainly you and shank well especially
on the big stuff on the big stuff
particularly let's hear about how did
you move from where you were to now
where you are considering also the fact
that you're openly gay you're married to
a dude yeah how exactly how about you're
saying it I put it into right really
yeah I mean look there's a lot here
first off I always find it funny and I
just tweeted something about this that
like people will look back on the way
you thought a couple years ago or
something you tweeted a couple years ago
or what you said a couple years ago and
then you see you say or do or think
something different now and they think
you're a flip-flopper or you've sold out
or some incarnation of that and I always
think how ridiculous and and sad
actually that is the one thing that
separates us from the animals is that we
can think we can learn we can actually
change our minds and I'm impressed when
people go you know I used to think that
way and now I think this way it doesn't
mean you abandon your ideals your morals
or all the other stuff that I think
we're going to talk about but it means
that you can take new information in and
change so without giving you the the
full long story of the full evolution
what I would say is when I was part of
the Young Turks a lot of it had to do
solely on the gay marriage thing that
the left was pounding this issue
and for me all I've ever wanted is equal
rights I don't want special rights I
don't want anything extra I want
equality of opportunity and that's it
and this one issue which directly
affected me personally I think it did
blur or color how I felt about some
other things you know I would like you I
was a political science major and it's
funny I think back now and a mic man
knowing what I think now about politics
and understand about freedom and the
people that have influenced me and that
I've been able to sit across and learn
from I don't know how I really thought
that much that I do I thought that the
left really made sense that the state
really made sense the collectivism made
sense but I do think partly what
happened was at least for a couple years
I was hijacked in a way my mind was
hijacked by that one issue yeah because
if you're not treated equally in some
way then that can become something that
colors everything else so it's not
totally about that but I think that was
a large part of it and then look gay
people are equal now everyone in this
country is equal I mean that's that's
the truth there are no laws on the books
right now that cause inequality that
doesn't mean inequality doesn't right is
that we don't live in a utopia and thank
God we don't live in a utopia by the way
because it's not real man and on the way
to utopia you get dystopia and I think
that we might be heading there right now
but I were trying to fight it right so I
would say basically once I once I woke
up and I started really seeing what the
left was and and the endless hysteria
that you know all about and the
attacking people's motives constantly
lying smearing basically turning on fox
news and going that's what they're doing
and we're gonna do the reverse that's
not a position to hold a position to
hold is something that you truly believe
in and understand where rights and
morals and all the rest of it comes from
and I would say more than anything else
my real evolution is because I do this I
mean every week I sit down with people
from you to jordan peterson to sam
harris to thomas soul and an incredible
array of thinkers and i I swear to eben
I sit there I look at them as you're
looking at me now and I try to take in
as much as I can and be as honest as
possible and I can see right now you
don't have a ton of notes on you I
didn't you know we talked a little bit
before and we're gonna do our thing and
that's how I try to approach an
interview I don't have a motive
I try to honestly hear these people
and sometimes you can figure it out when
someone doesn't know what they're
talking about but let them say it yeah
and let that be to let that let the
audience decide so I want to talk about
your interview style in just a second
and the people here there's been some
controversy associated with some of the
folks that you interview but I think
that you know of all the people that
you're talking about the one thing that
I've said that I think that all these
folks have in common is that they
actually like examining ideas and we're
not ripping on each other's motives
we're not constantly suggesting that
we're coming from a bad place trying to
do bad things and that more than
anything is I think what unifies this
group of people that and the fact that
there are a lot of people out there who
cut against their prevailing audiences
to say particular things absolutely I
mean think about this I take positions
that I mean we did it on my show just a
couple months ago right I you know you
know I'm pro-choice but grudgingly
pro-choice and I talked about the
20-week thing and you made an
interesting argument where you said you
know if you're saying it's a life at 20
weeks but it you know you can feel aim
that's my arguing that well I concede it
to you yes it is obviously a life at 18
weeks it's one of those issues that
whether we agree or disagree we should
be doing that right we should be having
that argument and I think out of this
whole crew of people whether it's Eric
or his brother Brett weinstein or
christina hoff sommers or sam harris or
whoever it is we're all taking some
unpopular positions that go against what
our base if you want to call it believe
that shows a little bit of character
that shows a little bit of of a desire
for truth and that's all we're trying to
do here and and really to your point
though I think how often to any of us
really attack people now look me and you
are big on Twitter and we fight with
spirit exactly now and again like every
but going on your way to attack somebody
for who they are is something that I
don't think any of us do none of us do
it and have we ever done it and slipped
up and you can word thing a certain way
or whatever yes of course but if you
really look at the breadth of work of
these people and all the times we've
come together and now a bunch of us are
doing public events and all that we
consistently are talking about ideas we
are not talking about people and that
simply does not happen with most of
what's going on with the left these days
they attack motives they attack your
your human the most inner part of you
and that's what they go for and it's
because they've grown fat they've
controlled the narrative for so long
that they don't want a debate
because they felt that they didn't have
to for so long and that's why I think so
many of them hate me yeah it's not that
they think I'm necessarily wrong it's
that I know what that is I was in it so
they can go it's like it's easy for them
to hate you you know right like it's
easy for them to hate Glenn Beck it's
easy for them to hate Prager and all
that because like we've always hated the
program the Conservatives but wait
here's one of us right and not only that
I mean they they look at they look at
folks like you and they say okay here's
a gay guy who's not toeing the party
line well that means that he must not
legitimately begin secretly must be
subscribing to playboy or something make
you blush right now but I assure you
that I'm gay I mean it just yeah even
that it doesn't matter we can talk about
that if you want but it's just to me
it's so we realize the tokenism and this
is one thing that does bother me on both
sides is the sort of tokenism that
adheres to both sides so on the one side
you'll see from the left this idea that
if you are gay then you cannot be
conservative or as you saw with Kanye
West if you're legitimately black or you
care about black folks then you can't
actually be a fan of president Trump's
you can't be an independent thinker in
any way and then I do think that there
are some folks on the right there's a
question about the right to which they
look at somebody like you or like a
Kanye and instead of saying that's an
individual who agrees me that's really
awesome they'll say look a gay guy
agrees with me yeah and all of a sudden
it's like ooh totally different whereas
I think the proper response to that is
okay so he's gay you know whatever like
we agree that's the important thing
right yeah I mean look this is where no
but nobody's fully right all the time
you know you mean like we all have our
internal biases we all are constantly
trying to figure well if you're if
you're an honest thinker you're trying
to figure out what's going on so yes to
both sides kind of pick and choose when
they want to play identity politics and
all that for me as someone that came
from the left eye I know it so well that
line of thinking and and it it basically
spread like a virus throughout all of
the left if you look at my show like the
first time I had you on which was almost
three years ago yeah and again we did
not know each other and I think you came
in very ready to fight like you were
like oh I'm sitting down with a lefty
right you were ready to fight and I
really was they're like yeah let's do it
and look what's happened in these last
couple years where we've become allies
in this yes so people say to me well you
don't attack the right enough now first
off
by and large I've been welcomed for all
of my differences I go to events that
you've been to I go to the the
turning-point event that we did in West
Palm Beach it was the biggest College
conservative gathering I think of ever
yeah basically I went up there I talked
about being gay married and pro-choice
and for euthanasia and a whole bunch of
things that are better completely
regular with your chin and guess what I
got a standing ovation not the Shapiro's
level ovation but I got a pretty good
that's a different thing to it but but
but that's the point so you cannot tell
me that these people are the intolerant
ones because I constantly see the
reverse of that and all I see is in
taunton life but they are you guys
genuinely are the tolerant ones and the
left this thing that I was talking about
has taken over every I mean from top
down from from Bernie to the women's
March and however low level you want to
go does that not mean that of course
there are some there are decent lefties
I think there's a lot of misguided me
but I don't believe these are all bad
people what I do believe is that we can
show them that actually if you really
care about live-and-let-live if you
really care about gay people or black
people are Muslim people or the rest the
only way to do that is let people live
free well how do you do that it's
through libertarian and this is the part
this is the place where there really is
a crossover because whether you're a
conservative libertarian or a
left-leaning libertarian libertarianism
I think is probably the wave of the
future in the sense that people want to
leave each other alone
for the most part like that that's why
abortion is such a big disagreement
because there are left-leaning
libertarians who say well that's a
woman's choice and right-leaning
libertarians like me who say well that's
an independent human child and so this
implicates actual Liberty issues but
it's why for example you start off by
saying that you were really on the Left
because of the gay marriage issue you
know I've been in in favor of government
getting out of the business of marriage
for years and years and years and years
before Obama was in favor of same-sex
marriage I was in favor of the
government getting out of the business
of marriage even though as a religious
person and you know this because we've
discussed this yeah as a religious
person I still think homosexual activity
is a sin but who cares we live in a free
country you can believe that I'm an
idiot
right I mean let's not gloss over that
point I really mean this I really want
to focus a with you here I genuinely
don't care right
I mean I really mean that like I hope
look hopefully then we'll be friends for
another 50 years and all
and will change will change the world to
be a freer place and all that and maybe
when we're 80 will do this again and
you'll go you know Dave after all these
years maybe maybe you're not a sinner it
doesn't it and I don't even think you
really view me that way and it truly
doesn't matter to me as long as you're
not coming onto my property and trying
to harm me and this will really need to
understand that and people need to
understand that I think in general about
religious folks is that just because
religious people think something is a
sin doesn't mean they think the
government should get involved or that
it's my job to lecture to you about the
sort of sin in which you are
participating particularly if this is
something that you know you're involved
in or you're set on like there's actual
counterproductive things that are being
done so they do this though is where I
think the Conservatives got a little
crossed up with the religious crew and
for years was doing too much moralizing
and preaching and for example so for the
years before gay marriage became law I
believe that you were taking the the
libertarian position on this yes the
government shouldn't be involved but
very a few conservatives we're doing
like Rand Paul for example should have
been screaming about that right he
should have said this has like I'm the
libertarian of you guys and bank
conservatives and Republicans that
should have been his mantle not because
he really I don't care what he thinks
about gay marriage one way or another
but he should have State staked out that
position and he could have led the
conservative I think that's who a more
principled position but but he didn't
because everyone's always playing
politics in their own little thing but
at the end of the day if you got guess
what it's the law of the land right now
so also and this is the case that I make
to religious people if you're a
religious leaning libertarian right who
believes that certain things are sins so
what
meaning that here's here's throw them
right exactly I don't sleep with the
dude eggs done we're there right exactly
and I think one of the things that I've
made the case do with religious people
is if you're a religious person and you
don't want the government cracking down
on you from the reverse side if you
don't on the state of California saying
same-sex marriages now the law of the
land and your church has to perform
same-sex marriages well then you should
be in favor of the government getting
entirely out of this business because
whatever the government touches it now
has the power to wield the gun on behalf
of so in a second I want to ask you more
about your interview set which it
becomes super popular obviously and in
some ways controversial first I want to
say thanks to our sponsor is over at
Boleyn
so as you can see we're never gonna
agree on everything but everyone can
agree that we all need more sleep and
getting a great night's sleep is easier
and more affordable than you think
you don't need a new expensive mattress
or sleeping pills what you do need to do
is change your sheets you know we're all
stupid about sheets we all drive past
the gas station we think it's a thousand
count thousand thread count sheet but
bringing home it's a tarp well this is
why you actually need to check out bowl
and branch because everything Bowl and
branch makes from there betting's their
blankets is made from pure 100% organic
cotton it starts out super soft and then
gets even softer over time you buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand bucks in the
store but bull and branch sheets are
only a couple of hundred dollars which
sounds expensive
it really isn't you're sleeping on them
every night we actually took all of our
old sheets and we threw them out and
bought a bunch of bowling bran sheets
because now I can't sleep on anything
else it's actually ruined to me everyone
who tries ball and bran sheets loves
them it's why they have thousands of
five-star reviews why Forbes Wall Street
Journal Fast Company they all love bull
and branch even three US presidents Plus
Bill Clinton's lovers sleep on bowl and
bran sheets shipping is free and you can
try them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send them back for a full refund
but you're not gonna want to because
there's no risk and no reason not to
give them a try to get you started right
now my listeners get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at Boleyn branch
calm promo code Ben go to bull and
branch calm today for 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets that Bo ll and
branch calm again use that promo code
Ben bow and branch comp remote code Ben
that lets them know that we say you and
gets $50 off okay so let's talk about
the popular to your show cuz obviously
you went from nothing to a million miles
an hour very quickly and you have you
have an enormous audience now huge
numbers of people tune in to your show I
know that the interview that you and I
is really more of a conversation that's
why that's what's great about your show
is it's not even an interview so much as
it as a conversation with the person
you're talking about which is great and
the interview that you and Jordan and I
did together has you were saying 3
million views on YouTube now and so you
guys become wildly popular so the area
where you're getting criticized a lot
from some folks is that you'll have a
not only a wide variety of people on but
people who they consider outside the
Overton Window and now I'm talking a
minute about kind of the construction of
the Overton Window and how dangerous
this is sure but what's your philosophy
when you decide how did you have a guest
who do you think it's worth sitting
across from because obviously not all
ideas are created equally valuable and
who do you think okay I'm not having
that dude on that guy's just jackass
yeah so it's a great question I'm glad
you asked it and I've been trying to
address this
but hopefully this will be the cleanest
one that I can do so my general belief
is if you are saying something that is
relevant and it's starting to percolate
up and I start seeing oh there's people
talking about you this idea is sort of
interesting this or that like just that
it's just a little bit of just like a
general Gestalt of things like I just
start feeling something and suddenly I
get a burst of people saying this is
that you got to look this way look this
way look this way so that's usually
where it starts
look there are cases so for example Mike
Cerner which is a good example of this
when I had Mike Cerner badge on it was
about two and a two years ago or so it
was right at the beginning of the Trump
thing and I on Twitter I'm seeing all
these people that are these big magnet
Trump people but I but they were all
anonymous and I couldn't find anyone
that was like a somewhat legit human
like a published author or a based on
their face I couldn't find anybody and
then suddenly CERN a started
popping up more and more and I looked
and he had this book and I was like all
right he's a published author seems kind
of interesting I think he was verified
on Twitter so I was like all right
there's something here and the night and
then I interviewed him by the way in my
interview we talked Trump basically for
an hour we talked some frustrations with
the left and just blah blah blah there
was nothing that was racist that I could
it wasn't you know it was before people
by the way so this is also a funny thing
where you interview someone then someone
does something a year later and then
people think how did you interview that
person or they literally tweet the
interview to me and say you didn't ask
him a pizza gate I'm like I don't have a
freaking tiny but really that everyone
just wants to get you all the time and
all that stuff now look assertive it's
done some things that I think are
somewhat shady like pizza gate yes at
the same time in the last year or so has
he done some interesting actual
reporting yes and at the same time has
the media absolutely collapsed and
become a completely unethical cesspool
of evil yes and I don't consider him to
be the worst part of that cesspool so I
have no problem doing that interview
when you especially when you take the
context of everything else I think the
one that people seem to be more annoyed
about so I so realistically look I've
done 300 400 interviews yeah so people
point to like two or three and I'm like
all right that's always the way all
right two or three so I think look
people were upset when I had my low on I
do not regret having my low on he was a
big personality yes he was a cultural
phenomenon for good or bad and look
where is my low now you know pretty much
irrelevant it comes out in the wash yeah
yeah so I don't but I have no regrets
for anything that I did with him I think
we had especially the second interview
with we talked it was two gay people
that had really wildly different takes
on things really going into some issues
that don't get discussed that often I
have no regrets and that one is good
also because it was clarifying I mean
there were certain things that he said
I'm an remember writing a column about
something that he said about you know
the value of political correctness and
saying okay well if this is what he
thinks here's why he's wrong and
clarification is a useful a useful tool
for sure happens people like yeah
obviously it's well publicized the Milo
and I do not get along yeah and are not
getting along began long before the
actual you know the actual move by the
alright you know involved with Milo it
started off when Milo was saying that
political correctness had to be
combatted by saying things that were
utterly vile and I was saying that's not
what political and correctness is and
that was partially elucidated I remember
I wrote a long column about this for
daily wire on your show right because
you had that conversation with us yeah
and and I'm glad you said that because
that gets to a little bit of why I
interview the way I do the only way I
could get him to that place right was if
I let him speak
not if I just browbeat him the second he
said something that I disagree with or I
found odious or you gotta let him speak
and then smart people will look at it
and then hopefully write an article
about it he'd say okay this is what's
wrong about this or that or the other
thing I think the one though that that
people seem to latch on to the most is
when I had stefan molyneux who's a
youtuber he's really interested in this
race and IQ stuff look he a lot of
people wanted me to have him on I had
done his show once or twice where we
basically it was unedited I made sure it
was unedited and it was I basically
talked about classical liberalism I
talked about the individual and limited
government and all that and we had a
perfectly fine exchange do I know every
bit of this guy's work know if you were
to add up all of the time that I've ever
watched of all of his videos and I don't
even think you get to an hour it's
probably it's probably significantly
less than that the obsession with race
and IQ is odd to me it's not it's an
extremely uncomfortable topic I mean
look what just happened with sam harris
and ezra klein and because of the
charles murray intern right sam being
completely right knows we're being
completely wrong yeah and yeah and that
yeah that
that's a whole other thing and it also
goes to show why the media is just so
awful once they get infected by social
justice Ezrin box have just been common
Melton I ended up on the same side of
Sam Harris man I mean like this is
what's happened now but you know almost
every speech that I give now I give a
shout out to you and to Sam because yeah
I always say this is the incredible time
we're living in yeah the first video
that I did of 2018 this is gonna be the
year of unusual alliances you and Sam
Harris disagree on everything literally
on everything from the most existential
questions of the universe and God hate
meaning and all of that to taxes to
abortion tobacco to datura yet your
allies yes this is a beautiful thing and
that's and that's why people are coming
to us by the way real quick though on
Miriam look he has an obsession with
that topic I even I made a point of
repeatedly asking him in the interview
why do you care about it so why do you
care now at the end of the day we link
to some articles that he referenced down
below and then I put it out there for
people to decide what they think it's
not my thing but the last thing I would
say about this because I don't think
it's worth yeah belaboring too long is
that you know my friend and mentor Larry
King you know in his in his heyday
picture in 1989 notes exactly and I love
Larry the fact that he even thinks I'm
remotely decent of doing this is the
most incredible thing ever but peak
Larry King let's say days when he's
introducing May the Israeli bonds Bank
Lane yeah exactly
ninety-four peak of OJ Simpson Gary King
on any given week Larry King five nights
a week on CNN could have had the cast of
friends on Monday Farrakhan on Tuesday
David Duke on Wednesday an animal guy on
Thursday and you know Lucille Ball at 80
years old on Friday no one in their
right mind would have thought he
endorsed all those ideas or he thought
thought all those people are friends or
whatever for some reason now if you sit
with someone if you chat with someone if
you just listen to someone you you
automatically endorse their ideas it's
such a dangerous slippery slope al and I
believe you just have to let it be if
people don't like what I do you don't
have to watch so here so here's the
obvious follow-up question just clarify
so are there people who you wouldn't
have on well of course there's people I
wouldn't have on I mean if you don't
have people in the conversation so say
Richard Spencer want to come on your
show
we don't have Richard Spencer so
obviously he's prominent so I'm glad you
have
that one he's actually not that
prominent anymore and and and who made
him prominent by the way it was the left
that kept propping him up as if he was
somehow the standard bearer for
conservatism or for the right or
something like that nobody there were
very few good conserved decent
conservatives which I think is the bulk
of conservatives that were like this
guys on it like these are the ideas were
pushing so as for Spencer look his ideas
that that the United States should be a
white ethno state or a whatever you want
to call them yeah those are so
absolutely ridiculously counter to all
of our founding documents to everything
that is great about this country but
there is no reason to give that air at
all now could someone say Dave you just
said this thing about Molyneux you gave
him here possibly like I'm willing to
entertain that and if at the end of this
you say you know Dave you really did
drop the ball on that one all right you
know what Ben you're not gonna leave
this but I'm not perfect it's crazy
right so I would say that those ideas
are so ridiculous but it's not just that
they're ridiculous those ideas are so
out of power in any way you can say
whatever you want about Trump and
whatever but he's not a white
nationalist he's not a white supremacist
the ideas of white supremacy don't have
power in mainstream media they don't
have power in the halls of politics or
any of those things so to focus on that
would just be giving it strength when I
talk about what's wrong with the left it
has infected the whole frickin thing
from top to bottom as I said earlier so
that's why I focus on that more but of
course there if you are literally
calling for murdering people and all I
have no need to talk to you and by the
way my show as you know my studio is in
my home I think that's a pretty good
rule of thumb if you don't want them in
your home then probably shouldn't have
them on your interview right I mean
we've had that we've had that debate
internally about some things
yeah we have same people have you found
it harder since you've made this shift
and now you
I mean you're very open with a number of
people and the kinds of people you
interviews you save had people left and
right have you found it harder to book
particular destination sign that's you
all these well they always call them
far-right well they're just basically
libertarians and it's like man if you
think Shapiro and Prager and the rest of
these guys and Larry Al there are
far-right whatever you mean by that like
you actually don't want to have a
conversation you know you truly don't
look most of my guests I think actually
have leaned a little bit left but
they've all been purged from the left
that's what's consistently happened so
let's talk about that because because I
wrote a column recently about the
reduction of the Overton Window it was
something specific about Kevin
Williamson and National Review and the
Atlantic hiring him and then firing him
within three weeks when they found a
tweet they didn't like and what the left
it seems to me is done and this is why
you and I are now in the same camp and
Sam and I are now in the same camp we're
all in the same camp together
is what the left has done is they've
created the Overton Window for people
who don't know is this this torment this
term that was coined for acceptable
elements of debate so not people you
agree with but people who are saying
things that are inside the realm of the
of the rational or inside the realm of
the reasonable or the decent let's say
and what the left has done is they've
closed that window so tight and unless
you agree with them on virtually
everything you are now no longer in the
Overton Window so for Sam he gets cast
out of the Overton Window for saying on
national TV that Islam is a more
dangerous religion than Christianity
because he's looking at the numbers of
adherents who are actually violent and
ben affleck calls him crazy and suddenly
sounds outside the Overton Window and he
doesn't end with Charles Marines at
least and suddenly Ezra Klein is calling
Sam Harris a racist for talking about
obviously well substantiated IQ studies
in a rational reasonable way which he's
not saying that all IQ differences are
biological and he's still getting cast
outside the Overton Window so do you
think that there's a way to open back up
the Overton Window or is the only way to
do this just by changing the gatekeepers
of the Overton Window or does it need to
be destroyed all together because there
are a lot of people who are saying well
it seems like there's three perspectives
one the Overton Window is is too small
and needs to be brought in a little bit
one is we need to change who gets to
decide who's in the Overton Window and
the third is no aversion whatsoever
everybody gets to talk every perspective
is to a certain extent equivalent in
terms of what should be heard and what
should not where do you stand yeah so
it's a great question I just did a video
a couple days ago where I said the
Overton Window hasn't just shifted it's
shattered because that's what that's
what's happened right now you're right
the left controlled the narrative for so
long that if you if you were a lefty who
dare say some unpopular things and Sam
really is the best exam
love this you will be purged who hates
Bill Maher now is it the right is it Ben
Shapiro I'm calling him on my show now
yeah even though you disagree with
probably all of his all of his policy
solutions are probably the complete
reverse and his takes on religion are oh
yeah you know like the thing about like
me being crazy for the thing on my head
yeah yeah okay but but right but yet
you're quoting him all the time right is
your basic premise of where you guys are
starting from this is because bill
really is a libertarian but he's gotten
sort of lost I think in some leftist
stuff and by the way I would love to
have this conversation with him at some
well yeah because great because he was
he wasn't he called himself libertarian
and he moved to the left while still
calling himself libertarian and now he's
finding that he actually is still
libertarian in his mind even though he'd
moved to the left but the audience is
left now so it's so fun but this is the
best thing as him yelling at his own
audience on a show it's incredible think
about this so it's funny so for all the
what what happens with Bill now he said
he says some unpopular thing and then or
the left now calls him racist and a
bigot but that's the same thing he was
doing to conservatives all those years
so he's become sort of a victim of his
own creation but but putting in aside
for a second on the Overton Window
question look it needed to be bigger
there is no doubt about that it needed
to be broadened so we could have some
honest conversations but we simply could
not so that every time a decent
conservative spoke up you were labeled
far-right and all right and everything
else look even with the Kanye tweets
what happens you know he sends out a
couple videos of Scott Adams you know
the Dilbert creator best-selling author
BuzzFeed mediate a bunch of others they
all wrote that Scott Adams is far-right
Candace I mean the twit the Twitter
elements thing happened when when
Candace Owens when Kanye tweeted about
Candace Owens Twitter moments the lead
thing far right Candace Owens can is a
friend of mine i'ma had her on the show
I have a lot of differences with her
which by the way we talked about
publicly who I was at Berkeley with her
a couple weeks ago I'm gonna be with her
next week doing something the idea that
she's far-right you may not like her but
this is what they do so then the window
deep did need to expand if it shatters
if it truly shatters well then we're in
this odd place where everything is equal
and every
should be entertained and that could be
dangerous but as a free speech guy I'm
all for those things being safe right
yeah you have to have a choice between
there being no Overton Window and in
Overton Window that's the small ya look
for people like us that take on popular
positions and say what we think all the
time we need that Overton Window to be
as wide as possible that but that's the
risk of freedom I mean this is the risk
consistently if you boo if you truly
believe in freedom not just cuz you say
you believe in freedom but if you really
want people to think for themselves
they're gonna start thinking some things
you don't like but then what's the
answer get people to be educated get
them to read some stuff get them to
listen to some interesting podcasts you
know Greg Gutfeld
who I think is doing a great job of
bouncing between mainstream media on Fox
News and kind of getting this
intellectual dark web thing he wrote a
great piece on how you know you barely
have to go to college at this point
because you can go on YouTube and listen
to lectures by Jordan Peterson and
Christina have summers and GAD sad and a
whole bunch of other people
you'll learn I think there's some issues
with that because you need college I
think for some of the socialization and
you know fun and some other talent at
home so exactly me to the parties yeah
that's why I'm you know that's why I've
got you doing videos with with Blaire
white but really I mean what even that
the fact that we had that conversation
about trans issues and that you you
admitted that you had a sort of public
position in a private position on this
and then you had the conversation with
Blair and now I've still got these crazy
people on Twitter telling me what a
homophobe you are yeah and that's why
they need to be ignored we don't need to
give them oxygen if you truly want to
make a better world if you truly want to
live in a country with 300 some odd
million people that are all gonna have
differences of opinion and that's
actually what makes us stronger then
those people just have to be ignored and
they're running out of steam by the way
so I want to talk about the the
technological reduction of the Overton
Window we'll talk about YouTube and
Facebook and what they're doing over
there in just a second but first I wanna
say thanks to our sponsors over at blue
apron so for six weeks from April 16
through May 21st blue apron is teaming
with Airbnb to bring you the best home
cooking from around the world each week
their menu is featuring a recipe
developed in collaboration with an
Airbnb experiences host like Cece who's
a chef from Shanghai who makes
apparently incredible
kung pao chicken a beloved sticky saucy
mix of crispy brown chicken and
vegetables it sounds delicious and blue
apron delivers fresh pre-portion
ingredients and step-by-step recipes
right to your door that can be cooked in
under 45 minutes everybody at our office
is using blue apron the menu changes
every week based on what's in season and
it's designed by blue aprons in-house
keulen Airy team and blue apron offers
12 new recipes each week customers can
pick two three or four recipes based on
what best fits their schedule if you
have kids it's really fun to cook with
them and blue apron makes it really easy
blue apron sends only non GMO
ingredients and meat with no added
hormones so check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals free at
blue apron comm slash Shapiro that's
blue apron comm slash repair to get
those first three meals for free blue
apron is a better way to cook okay so
David you've had some bad experiences
with YouTube YouTube has been constantly
D monetizing your videos which obviously
has to your income considering
that you are largely a YouTube based
platform and you're you're moving into
new areas of revenue which I'm really
excited about for you because I think
it'll just expand your capacity to do
all the things you're already doing
which is awesome but what we've seen is
that and I've been talking openly about
those members of Congress what we've
seen is that there were these
gatekeepers to the media it used to be
NBC ABC CBS and then the internet
destroyed all of that and you can get
information from wherever you wanted and
then there were these new platforms
Facebook and YouTube and Twitter and
they said you know what we're just
platforms we're places where you can
gather your audience and expand your
audience and you don't have to worry
about us shutting it down because we're
not ABC NBC CBS we don't have an
editorial board that decides what people
can see and what people can't see and
then they lied it turns out that they
are all actors publishers and they are
shadow banning or they are d monetizing
so you've had videos with me they've
been D monetized get a video Thomas so I
can't make a dime off you should be
right exactly I don't know why making
time off of you so who figured it out
this is the cultural appropriation we
were talking about but you know it's
with the orthodoxy comes greater earning
power so I'll bring you back so what you
really do that's right we're the secular
do you think we should talk about that
okay we'll talk about that in a second
so it but the hell have you been dealing
with that and what do you think is the
solution cuz there are some people
saying you know regulate YouTube's a
public utility
I'm always troubled by the idea of
additional regulation in the space do
you think it's possible to build a
competitor something like a YouTube or
Facebook considering the market share
dominance that these companies actually
have what do we do about this because
again you had a conversation with Thomas
Sol
that was automatically
monetised with thomas solo yeah I didn't
know how that's humanly possible Ben as
a guy in a yarmulke you know the story
of David versus Goliath I've sort of
become Dave verse YouTube I mean I I've
been one of the most outspoken people on
this because it's impossible to tell
what's going on if let's say they just
had a clear one pager this is what we
monetize this is what we don't this is
our policy well ice nobody forced me to
be on YouTube I'm voluntarily there they
don't have to monetize anything but
really they I truly I mean I tweet this
all the time they can do whatever they
want the only reason I'm screaming about
it all the time is I can only use my
voice to influence things I don't want
government involvement the idea that the
government but the United States
government is gonna somehow regulate a
tech company properly is bananas it's
completely I don't even own a computer
is I mean if you watch that here on the
Zuckerberg it was just like they don't
know what is the Facebook is it a book
full of faces Ben I just paid my
property taxes you know a month ago on a
government website it looked like he was
a AOL from 1996 nothing they could be
idea that these people can do this or
that middle management regulators can
figure out it makes you hate taxes
anymore because I think all your money
they know these crowded web sites but
yeah the hour that I lost in my life
just watching the things like dial-up
prodigy like ridiculous so the idea that
the government can do it is not the
answer to me what I think we can do and
I think you're doing it too is we can
influence them by leveraging our
audience to know what's going on it's
the lack of transparency that's the
problem
and it's also look the only reason I
keep making such a big noise about it is
because things like Thomas all things
like Ben Shapiro thoughts I mean it's
it's all over the board and by the way
you know there's this idea out there
that this is only they're only attacking
conservatives or they're only attacking
people that are thought of as more right
or whatever I am or whatever I don't
know that that's the case I genuinely
have no idea what's going on but I will
consistently use my voice because that's
what you're supposed to do as a citizen
I'm not asking the government and yes do
I think competition can come in yes now
the one counter-argument to this and I
think it's a legit one and I think
perhaps our our friends at Prager
University to view this a little
differently than us is that Google which
owns YouTube obviously controls so much
information has so much power now
that it is possible that by default that
competition can never really arise
against them now I actually don't take
that position but I think there's an
interesting argument to be had there I
believe they'll they'll ultimately
crumble under the weight of their own
nonsense if you're gonna say well and we
know this because of the d'amour lawsuit
well we're not gonna hire white or Asian
engineers guess what you're gonna start
getting not the best engineers and
that's not a knock on any ones ethnicity
or anything but you should be hiring
it's really standard as merit it's
different than if that is not your only
standard precisely so yeah so they will
crumble on their own and if we have to
push them a little bit so that
ultimately something else can arise then
then so be it
but I would be look if they if tomorrow
it all gets fixed like every time I
email them I'm like guys I want this to
work
yank I'm enjoying this but I assure you
every time we see the demonetized thing
and we request you and one of my guys
tells me I mean I'm not gonna repeat
because I know this family show usually
say at first but then I'm like I mean I
got to do it again and then I got to
take the screenshot and I got a tweet
it's like this is not what I want to put
out a show yeah get people to check it
out let the ideas fall that where they
may and then move on but no I don't
think the government is the answer and I
think what you're doing what I'm doing
what Phil DeFranco is doing and Rogan
and the rest is the answer keep putting
out good stuff and force them to do the
right thing now the one area where where
I'd be curious your thoughts is what
I've suggested is if they're gonna act
via acting like publishers then they
ought to be treated by publishers
meaning we here at the Daily wire if I
publish a story that is libelous then
The Daily wire can be sued for that
because we control the flow of
information if you're Facebook and you
are D grew and you're taking certain
content and you are whitewashing it or
you're moving it off the front pages and
you're taking other content you're
elevating that it seems to me that
unless you're doing that in the most
neutral possible way you are now
publisher you're deciding what goes up
and what goes down and which ends uncle
Berg himself said we're now responsible
for what goes up well obviously it
doesn't mean that because it means that
they will be out of business within five
minutes just for simple copyright
violation I mean there's probably tens
of thousands of copyright violations
that happen on Facebook every single day
with people grabbing other people's
photos and sticking them on Facebook my
feeling is that if they're gonna they're
gonna act like publishers they got to be
treated like publishers and if they want
to act like platforms like an AT&T phone
line then act like an AT&T phone line
don't don't tell me that you're acting
like an AT&T phone line
monetizing Dave Rubin well actually
spending money to promote chanc right so
of course so so I read your piece on
that and I think it's a perfectly sound
argument I'm still worried even even
granting you all of that I'm still
worried about where that would lead if
they were to be viewed as a publisher
and said because it still creates a
problem with the government and I just
don't think the government can solve
this thing I think competition is the
only thing they can but very quickly on
that we know that they have partners I
mean with you Matt the groups that
they've decided that are monitoring
content they're all far-left groups the
channels that they whitelist like The
Young Turks I mean they're the entrence
is a far left by every estimation
they're a far left news organization now
because the media never calls anything
far left versus mainstream right exactly
they would never call Bernie is far left
I mean that is the truth but they never
call him far left they is a hero and
your far right so again I mean that gets
us back to the overt and window thing
but I would say competition is the
answer and we just have to keep putting
out good stuff and and we will survive I
mean this is exactly why I'm on patreon
because YouTube rev it just makes no
sense and I know and you know I'm
working on some other things partly
partly because you hooked me up with
something and and we'll go from there
okay so let's I can survive oh no you're
doing you're doing great and the fact
that your audience continues to grow is
presenting a real threat to a lot of
these outlets because again if they
don't get to choose which outlets have
the viewers the money will find the
viewers I mean that's just the way
advertising works so eventually they're
gonna look and they're gonna say dave
rubin has enormous numbers and whether
we get you the money another way or
whether we get you money through youtube
the money's coming so I think what a
funny thing that is I mean you said this
on on the sit down we did with Jordan
when you were like man we're the best we
got yeah exactly like like how did this
happen where there's this like 20 of us
that you know I think we're all good at
different things right and whatever but
like how did it all suddenly fall on
these 20 people and now Kanye is
actually given a lot of oxygen to this
yeah even forgetting his politics yeah
forgetting the crazy of him it's bottom
line is that you know as soon as they're
there a certain number of people who are
willing to treat other people as
individuals and those people are all
being kind of placed into the same
category I mean I've written about this
now a bunch of times for National Review
just the idea again that if you look at
the the panoply of people who are now
friendly with one another it
people like Sam and you and me and
Jordan and Brett Weinstein and Eric I
mean like I don't know if you can have a
more polarized set of people politically
than that I need a more unified group of
people who want to have honest
conversations than that ins because they
reject identity politics which i think
is at the core of all this so I want to
talk to you a little bit about you know
Dave Rubin the human because we got Dave
Rubin the set of views all the time the
robot now let's go exactly I never allow
me people to ask me this question
because then then everything goes on the
fritz and I start the sparks start
coming out of my head no that's what the
yarmulke hides but it's not horns it's
actually my wiring but the exactly so
let's talk about kind of what your
life's like as you mentioned the secular
Jew versus religious do you think so
where are you religiously what is it
that you believe so it's interesting so
first a start kind of at the end here
and then I'll go backwards you know it's
funny I because I interviewed a lot of
atheists in a row and when we started my
show as the interview show on or a TV
the first interview I did was with Sam
and then subsequently I got on a lot of
the skeptic community the atheists
whatever I loved having those
conversations I know you like that by
the way is it and I think the most
important conversations right anyway so
yeah that's whether we agree or disagree
that's what it's all like what is going
on here let's figure it out and why do
you think it it's a wonderful
conversation to have but anyway I had a
whole slew of them guys that I really
really liked from wide ranges of
backgrounds from God sad and people go
Xion and Michael Shermer and a whole
whole slew of people all over the place
politically ethnically etc and because
of that people started saying that I was
an atheist I had never said I was an
atheist but people kept saying it then I
was on I think the first time I had Milo
on and Milo was ripping atheism and it
basically I felt he kind of put me into
a place where I kind of had to cement I
yeah I had to defend it but but even
more I felt that I sort of had to say I
was an atheist and I said it and I don't
think I had ever said it privately to
anyone or even I didn't think it quite
summed up what I believe but because of
that then about a year and a half goes
by and I I went off the grid last August
and I'm trying to do it every year now
and when I was off the grid every
seventh day we I'm doing this you know
I'm do I'm trying to do this off social
media on the weekends they said you
tweeted yes well we have a whole
religion built around this just for you
Dave
yeah yeah you guys need to
that you guys exactly needs to extend it
into a 48-hour period that's how people
Twitter is but baddest oh yeah bad aside
I came back and I had been off the grid
for a month and I I suddenly I just had
this feeling when I was away and away
from the nonsense and I literally didn't
look at the news once I did not watch TV
once I didn't look at social media
nothing that I really what the word
atheist did not sum up my beliefs it
just did it felt too limiting to me
so I basically said I don't like that
word anymore and then all hell broke
loose because they were all pissed to me
and like right now you're from Jew and
they you know a theist being a fully
observing from Jew and no longer gay
married you know look at all these
interesting people that come to this
conversation I mean you look you work
with Andrew Clayman was was born Jewish
in aus County was a Catholic Protestant
or the president Drew's proud okay okay
Faraday's question yeah it's Christian
right so what I would say is this just
quickly on my background I grew up in a
in a conservative Jewish home and we did
Shabbat on Friday night I'm with you I
get your body aren't we do for a Shabbat
when we are well I mean I think my wife
has to get out of like chess to cook
dinner
Illinois's woman oh he's working because
the doctor you've heard and I know
people are now saying why don't you cook
dinner Shapiro because I refuse to cook
dinner that's the answer I want a
computer cooking me a Shabbat dinner Wow
yeah I don't know that feels that feels
no I know women feel like this is so
like in a conservative Jewish household
New York you know it was it was the
stereotypical Jewish household of people
fighting over politics all the time
fighting over everything and then with
the meal would finish and we'd be fine
and you know I would be at the when we'd
have holidays you know Passover you
whatever Russia China you know huge
tables of people and I'd usually be at
the kids table when I was young but I
always wanted to be at the adults table
because I wanted to be more funny
arguing and fighting and and you know
all of that stuff and talking politics
with everybody I did a semester in
Israel I didn't know that yeah in junior
year of college
nice 97 at fair share of a university or
ben-gurion University in bersia I I
would say this in terms of religion I
have a huge cultural identity to the
history of the Jewish people these are
my people this is the story of my people
and by the way it's a very depressing
and sad and painful history I mean but
that's the irony you know it's
my favorite line about Jewishness is
from fiddler on the roof when Tevye says
you know were the chosen people I wish
he just could have chosen someone else
you know it's a painful history we
sitting here is three thousand years of
horror punctuated by the occasional
triumph yeah and and some humor that got
mixed in I mean that's what happened
because a lot of horror creates a lot of
humor yeah yeah what I mean you know
comedy is tragedy plus time yeah like
that that's what it is I mean it's not a
coincidence that Jews are generally
funny
I mean it actually isn't a coincidence
so I would say I have a huge affinity
and and cultural attachment to that and
I understand the history of my people
and even if I had no attachment to that
it's still real it's still it still
exists I can't sit here and I think this
is where you kind of want to go at this
and say that none of those beliefs none
of that that set of ideas because it's
not about just saying a word but right
set of ideas that this comes from that
the idea that that has nothing to do
with what I think right now is is
completely crazy but I was I would also
say this that on the god front you know
a lot of Jews there there's a huge
amount of secular Jews I would say it
like a Steven Pinker really has into
this where or or even well Sam you know
I don't know if Sam technically I don't
know what he technically is he considers
himself at this point but I would say a
Steven Pinker Eric Weinstein would be
terrible is people who are there really
skeptics atheists but absolutely Jews
you know I mean they identify with and I
think ben-gurion sort of had a take on
this too that if you identify with the
history of these people that that sort
of is enough I mean it says in the Book
of Ruth right your people are my people
and my god and your God my God but it's
people first and then God which is
really interesting sort of transitioned
biblically yeah I didn't know that line
but but there you go that that makes
some sense to me so but I would say all
of these people have a certain there's a
sort of a certain wrestling with God a
certain well that does know and that
there's so much of that in duties or
that I see that too right I mean this is
the word Israel literally means struggle
with God I mean yesterday L is it means
struggling with God says write in the
Bible so this is certainly nothing new
you want to talk more about Judaism but
first let's make some money with our
friends over at Zeile is a this service
is honestly fantastic okay I'd use eel
for my wife for my parents for my
in-laws it will buy you some really good
ins with your in-laws okay because
here's what Zeile does whether
your back hurts from running after your
kids or your muscles are sore from
working out you're stressed after a long
day at work or doing an interview with
me zeal brings you same-day in-home
massages with the best licensed and
vetted massage therapists right to your
home so you go to zeal calm or on zeals
iPhone or Android app that zeal spelled
ze Elcom and you select from top local
licensed pre-screened massage therapists
you can choose your favorite technique
your gender preference your time and
location for your massage and zeal we'll
send one of their 10,000 licensed
massage therapists with a massage table
and the music and the supplies they
basically make a spa right there in your
home for a five-star massage scheduling
booking payment it's fast and it's easy
even the tip is included so 7 days a
week 365 days a year
SEO massage therapists can be at your
door in as little as an hour they're all
top-notch folks privacy convenience
quality comfort that's what you're gonna
get with your massage on demand from
Sheila I always say you don't actually
have to be rich to feel rich and one of
the things about deals it makes that
happen for you find out for yourself why
zeal has been featured in The Wall
Street Journal New York Times on Good
Morning America again bring the spa to
you try zeal today like as in today they
are on demand and you can have the best
massage of your life in your home with
zeal right now to help you get started
our listeners get twenty five bucks off
their first massage with promo code bet
and that zeal spelled z ee l comm promo
code been right now again zero morons
eels iphone or android app and get that
special offer when you try seal enter
promo code been twenty-five bucks off
your first in-home massage it's just
fantastic you'll really enjoy it okay so
back to the religion question so okay
let's let's get down to brass tacks so
where are you on God knows you're not an
atheist and you're also not you're not
coming to show with me so where is oh
you know what I will I will gladly go to
shul with you and see what's going on oh
it'll be a while and I know it's a lot
of mumbling and a lot of chuckling as
you know you know I would be more than
happy yes and you know Prager does the
the Yom Kippur service I think yeah
exactly yeah I'm happy to do those
things I like you know Eric Weinstein by
the way who is who's in effect a secular
non-believer I've been to his house for
Shabbat yeah and he does it so so that's
why that's the confusion generally
around Judaism whether it's a culture I
identify with the culture Ram so I know
I don't like the word atheism related to
what I believe I don't know that I can
fully tell you what I believe I just
don't and I know some people will say oh
that's some sort of cop out here or
something but I I have a belief in
something I
would say I'm far more of Zionist than I
am religious easily I think you can make
you know Sam wrote a piece a long time
ago which was people people on the left
hate him for about a secular argument
basically for Judaism or for Israel not
Israel yeah he's not making an argument
I could I don't the the religious party
whether you were wearing your yarmulke
or now or not doesn't matter to me
whether we happen to be taping this on a
Friday whether you like Handel's tonight
or not doesn't matter to me specifically
but that there is this absurdly tiny
oasis that is a place on earth for this
group of people who have been
slaughtered throughout time who by the
way are just returning to their homeland
of thousands of years ago well you know
all these people say well Jews just took
this place they just came in and took it
they're awful lot of old Hebrew place
where oldest Hebrew came from right so I
would say I'm a much bigger believer in
that that that I believe every people
have a right to self-determination and
Jews finally got it and who hates it the
most it's the last immunity yeah yeah
it's so sad
the one place that defends any of their
beliefs any of their beliefs in the
Middle East that is by far the most
tolerant place that's the place they
hate the most
yeah and it's also the place that has
given more equality to more people in
the Middle East than anywhere else I
mean there's basically there's bait
pretty much no Jews that live in the
Arab world anymore
yeah there's almost no Chris Christians
ask the Coptic Christians how's it going
in Egypt these days there was one Jew I
went to Egypt years ago there was one
Jew there I just heard that he's out of
there so like there's literally nothing
left and there's this one place that is
a tiny bastion of freedom that is
absolutely imperfect like every other
state but that has to be under endless
assault by not only just physical
assaults but has to be under assault by
these crackpots at the UN all the time
I'm a much bigger and what am i
defending I'm not defending I'm not
defending peoples that want to convert
people or we expand up people all right
I'm defending people's right to live in
freedom that's it I don't even want to
get into how that route is related to
just the peace process in all that cuz
we can show on that book I'm happy to do
that well that's it so you know I think
that we're moving toward the end of the
show and for
but I want to ask you where do you think
that you are going in the next five
years so obviously you've been doing
this for three or four years with all
the interviews what do you think is the
future for dave rubin you know fast
forward five years down the line i mean
i get all kinds of crazy offers and
fortunately because my audience has been
good to me and while we're doing on
patreon i've said no to things that
would make me a lot more money I mean
then I'm making right now and I know
that I'm in a great position to figure
out what I truly want to do I mean look
I built a home studio my my commute it's
a nice studio yeah yeah but my commute
is ten minutes ten steps not ten minutes
ten steps for my bedroom that's that's
pretty good we've built a small lean
strong business I'm you know we pay all
of our employees health insurance and
all kinds of other benefits and all that
and I'm so proud of what we built and
it's so consistent with the ideas that
I'm constantly talking about so if
people ask me all the time like one of
these days is its most likely gonna be
Fox I would guess because CNN and MSNBC
don't seem to want to do anything yeah
well CNN I'll put you on every now and
again
okay then I not want them no no no I
know that's pretty sweet but look could
one of these places make me an offer
that it would be crazy for me to say no
to and I don't mean that just because of
money because it's not about that no I'm
happy really I'm contented with what I'm
doing I want it to grow but but I'm in a
good spot but yes if you really if you
really believe in what you're doing you
want it to get to as many people as
possible so could one of those offers
come and then I'm gonna have to make
some kind of Sophie's Choice or
something yeah it could come and I and I
look forward to it coming and we'll see
what happens but I would say in terms of
what I really want
it's I want these conversations to
continue I truly truly believe this we
then are now part of something that is
is resetting the system I really believe
that the the whole country the dialogue
social media everything got so out of
whack so haywire that Trump possibly was
the only thing that could have rebooted
it but we're now in the reboot phase
that's not a commentary on Trump I
believe we're in the reboot phase now
you know it's like when you press reset
on Nintendo and you get back to the
beginning and now you got to play again
I think we've hit that button and now
it's like holy cow there is fertile
ground for good ideas so if I can
continue being part of that conversation
keep finding allies we're three years
ago I would have found
keep being a part of what you're doing
what all of these guys who we've
mentioned ad nauseam now here are doing
it's like how cool is that
it is really neat you know it's fun yeah
really a lot you know I walk down the
street and people peep first up I walk
down street people say may the force be
with you I mean that's amazing
people literally some guy was walking on
speed the other day some guy just yelled
out classical liberalism and gave me a
high-five and we just kept walking I'm
like like ideas are taking root and and
let's look we live in crazy times so
let's try to fix it a little bit
otherwise what the hell are we doing
exactly mr. Fixit give me the one thing
that the right needs to do and then give
me the one thing that the left needs to
do if we want to have a country in five
years so the left look what they've
needed to do is exactly what I was
trying to get them to do was please rein
in your most extreme forces
unfortunately they're simply unable to
do it because of the oppression Olympics
because of how identity politics works
and because of grouping people based on
immutable characteristics in a constant
competition they have the idea that
intersectionality makes them stronger
like it's gonna be like you know a
couple Decepticons forming Devastator
right there's gonna be a bigger better
robot but that's not how it works it
becomes a bigger crippled monster and
that's so I don't know at this point if
there's anything that they can do right
now I would love believe me if there was
a decent Democrat out there if there was
a Blue Dog Democrat like an old school
if Edie Koch magically reappeared or
Daniel Patrick Moynihan or JFK you know
they all in common they're dead but if
those people actually reappeared and
said we're gonna try to fix what is
wrong with the Democratic Party instead
of going the Bernie Elizabeth Warren
Kamala Harris route I'd be freaking
thrilled I was thrilled it's not gonna
happen what the right can do I and I
think you can be a big part of this
there is such an opening for you guys
right now we're all of the same people
that have just had it with this nonsense
are gonna start pushing your way I think
you've done a really nice job of sitting
down with these people and I think the
more that that can take root and
conservatism the agree to disagree which
i think is pretty much happening but the
more that that truly takes root where
you guys go you know we're gonna be
we're gonna have to be okay with the
idea of pro-choice we don't have to put
it in our party platform that's row or
what
but like we're gonna have to find some
allies that believe some different stuff
is us and the more that you guys do that
I think you will find you will have
incredible an incredible ability to
build something new and that would be
something that I would be proud to be
part of and I at this point I think
you're gonna find it very easy to do
actually so I that's what I hope will
happen and then suddenly there'll be
this new party or new movement that will
be be widest tent and it will only be
the widest tent because the other guys
pushed us all out exactly well this is
the part where we grip our hands like
rock III and form John biceps and it's
incredibly do rocky 4 will go to Russia
and fight on Christmas Day we'd get
serious numbers oh my goodness well I'm
not sure I could take you you've been
working out I here lost 17 pounds that's
amazing but for your data I'm off the
the bread you're living clean in the
news it's great to have you well good
luck with your show you don't need luck
you're already doing great so it's great
to see you I'll see you soon thanks so
much for the venture Piro shows Sunday
special is produced by Jonathan hey
executive producer Jeremy borin
associate producers Mathis Glover and
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and our
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha Oliveira and title
credits by Cynthia and gula the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018